Donald Trump seemingly extraordinarily
impaired and Confused gave a speech to
guests at Mar-A-Lago and seems so
disconnected from reality that it's hard
to know what is going on in his brain if
anything it may be the sort of situation
where you know the wheel is spinning but
the hamsters have long died and flown
off of the wheel I don't know here is
Donald Trump claiming that Joe Biden
convinced Vladimir Putin the president
of Russia to invade the nation of
Ukraine what when did that conversation
even reportedly take place listen to
Trump and I apologize the audio is not
exactly perfect of everyone's mind the
power is so destructive that we won't
talk about it I brought in professors
during the debate I've learned in
professors uh I want to talk about
nuclear case and Chippy and I brought
him in from MIT I said how would you
respond when we start talking about that
where they said sir sir and the best you
can to not talk about it it's something
you really can't talk about it's so
destructive it's so powerful the world
will be gone and now I hear this and we
have a man
who has no mind left and his mind in
prime time wasn't any good but he has no
mind left and this is the guy
negotiating for us we have a man that
convinced Putin to go into Ukraine
because if you look at the psychology
that he used it's the exact opposite
Putin would have never ever gone and he
knew the ramifications do you remember
when Biden said well they might take
some small parts of Ukraine that was
that's what Putin wanted to hear
there'll be no problem if you take some
parts of Ukraine delusional but
dangerously so and I also I I don't
really know what goes on at Mar-A-Lago
I'm going to be down there in a couple
weeks uh maybe I'll drive over and see
if I can figure out what the hell is
going on at Mar-A-Lago but in all
seriousness
I don't even know if the guests are
always expecting to hear this type of
insanity from Trump sometimes it seems
like he's just supposed to be
congratulating someone on a wedding or
something like that not at this
particular event Donald Trump also
attempted to rewrite history in this
very strange speech
um trying to rewrite history about
Ashley Babbitt the woman who was who was
killed at the January 6th Insurrection
listen to this it's what's happening to
our country Ashley Babbitt's mother was
arrested yesterday
because she was protesting the death of
her daughter being shot by a lunatic
who's a got a record of not so good and
then they try and protect him and they
do things with what they've done to that
family but they shot her there was no
reason and they arrested because the
mother was in a group and they arrested
yesterday the mother of Ashley Babbitt
so she loses her daughter and then on
top of it she gets arrested and we uh I
can let this go on now
shot by a lunatic Ashley Babbitt did
nothing wrong I I want to remind all of
you Ashley Babbitt was the 35 year old
Air Force veteran who was fatally shot
while she was participating in the
Insurrection on January 6 2021 in
Washington D.C she was part of a group
of trump supporters who breached the
Capitol Building during that attempt at
certifying the 2020 election results she
was shot by Capitol Police when she was
trying to climb through a broken window
that shooting was was investigated now
in every other case these Republicans
say was investigated police did nothing
wrong they were cleared we support the
police he here they aren't satisfied
with the investigation oh what a
surprise here they say despite the
investigation clearing the police
officer she certainly was doing nothing
wrong the shooting was investigated the
officer was cleared of any wrongdoing I
thought they supported the police I
thought they always agreed with the
exonerations of police officers no it's
yet another one of these principles
that's not a principle it's a principle
if the outcome is the outcome they want
and if it's not then it's very very bad
we're going to take a very quick break
and be back with more right after this
one of our sponsors today is Magic spoon
the breakfast cereal with the crunchy
sweet goodness you love but with high
quality ingredients less sugar and more
protein magic spoon has zero grams of
sugar it's packed with 13 to 14 grams of
protein and just four to five net carbs
so it's great if you're doing keto or
low carb or if just like me you're
trying to limit your sugar intake they
have many unique flavors so you'll never
get bored my personal favorite is maple
waffle but I grew up in New England so
maybe that's why Maple you know they
also have cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter blueberry muffin honey nut
cookies and cream cinnamon roll
sometimes there's really just no
substitute
for sitting down with a nice bowl of
cereal who doesn't love that when the
mood strikes go for something more
wholesome with plenty of protein and
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked simply go to
magicspoon.com Pacman you can create a
custom bundle and use the code Pacman
for five dollars off the link is down
below